this is an important time to talk right
now because the president has talked
about a transition point what he sees is
sunnier days ahead but no one including
the president has denied that what's
immediately come coming is as painful as
it can get each day what is forecast
ahead 30 million people plus out of work
right now yes that's true and we are in
a severe contraction which of course
comes from the economic consequences of
the virus it's nobody's fault it just is
there and the strong steps the president
has taken to deal with the virus which
has put us medically terms of public
health in a much better position I mean
the curve is flattening out and you've
seen states now beginning to use our
federal guidelines put together by
President Trump vice president pence as
metrics if you will it's going to be
data driven health and safety is first
but a lot of states are either beginning
to or about to reopen that'll help the
economy but no there's no question
Harris this is a deep painful hardship
ridden contraction it is not completed
yet is it too early to talk about
recovery when we don't know what the end
will look like I mean dr. pouchy with
the task force you you sit with him
every day I mean it was pretty jarring
to hear him use this word about a second
wave not potential any longer inevitable
well look Tony pouchy is a longtime
friend he is an expert and I think he's
taking account of all the possibilities
and probabilities that's his job and he
does a very good job of it I will say
this this we are I believe based on the
numbers flattening out that the May is
going to be a transition month for
reopening the economy let's just call it
May and spilling over into early June
we've been meeting with businesspeople
large and small companies CEOs almost
everybody people are looking towards
reopening and I think when you see that
it is a turning point I don't think
that's an unfair word to use or it's
it's not unrealistic to hope this is a
turning point we have very high hopes
that given the huge rescue package put
together by President Trump with the
Senate in the house I mean we've
actually put in the Federal Reserve and
the budget stuff Harris you're talking
about roughly nine trillion dollars it's
a remarkable thing
it's about cash and liquidity and
survival and payrolls and small
businesses and all the rest that you've
been reporting on I think let me go to
the Congressional Budget Office which
has bravely and boldly put out forecasts
they're looking for a very significant
snap back beginning this summer and into
the fall they're saying the second half
of this year
real GDP could grow seventeen twenty
percent and by the way they're also
looking at a near three percent growth
rate for 2021 I believe it actually will
do better than that but I think just
there and a lot of private sector
forecasters ours have similar views to
the CBO I'm an optimistic president
Optima bath